practice Sheila I don't know if this is
something you're gonna explore in the
future so if you can talk about this but
have you guys ever discussed why she
chose to become a wolf to begin with we
never did he's actually the answer I was
thinking about it but we never had overt
conversations I've done a lot of kind of
like journaling and like you know work
on that and I think it comes from and
there's something that I like I like to
keep private you know just because I do
think there's a huge part of her that is
like mysterious and weirdly not to like
pivot to this but it was something that
came up and we were working on Perry
Mason I know obviously it's a crime
drama and and crime is about eventually
hopefully understanding something that
happened but something that's so
devastating about life is sometimes you
don't get to know sometimes why things
happen you don't get to know and so I
love that about life I I mean it's hard
and painful and kind of motivating but
it's also quite can be really beautiful
so I also kind of love the idea that
nobody gets to really know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]